with us in Georgia - Dell how are you
I'm doing well how are you mr. Ramsey
better than I deserve what's up by
hundreds of a little late to the game
but I'm ready to join accounts with my
husband into one account together
I was also okay he's also looking into
getting a house as well which I am not
comfortable with because I don't think
we can afford it but he says that we can
I have credit cards attached to my name
which is why he doesn't want to go
forward with the joining accounts
because he doesn't want his name to be
attached to credit cards I don't have
any credit card debt it's just literally
an excellent credit score's that's it
and I feel a little uneasy about moving
forward in our Financial Peace
University steps to put up my credit
cards because we're living in Savannah
and I have yet to honestly look around
and see what's available in that market
for the house he's looking at purchasing
it's like a $65 honey I'm not working
right now going to school he's receiving
a GI disability payments from his rating
and stuff like that which is about
$2,000 a month where it's honestly
living off of savings currently writing
a home but plan on moving to a smaller
place so we could have a little bit more
room in our budget but I'm kind of stuck
and I'm not sure how to feel better
about moving forward we are looking into
following your plan for Financial Peace
University so I was wondering what
didn't so you had on that well were you
to follow our plan in Financial Peace
University you would get completely out
of debt and you would chop up every
single credit card you're using credit
cards as an emotional security blanket
and that is not healthy spiritually
emotionally or financially somehow your
credit score has given you comfort which
is a misnomer all that means is you've
borrowed a lot of money
paid it back that's where your credit
score came from it doesn't mean that you
have any money there is no comfort in a
credit score
except for your ability to go deeply in
debt if something happens which would be
really stupid so I would tell you to get
on the same page get in agreement about
what your long-term plans are under what
circumstances you're both going to feel
good about this in other words if Sharon
and I are looking at something and let's
say for instance we'll use buying a
house and she says you know I don't
really want to do that so yeah I do want
to do that well we don't do it until we
solve her reason for not wanting to do
it and if we never solve that we don't
do it we have to have unity on major
financial decisions because people who
do not do that do not prosper nor do
they prosper in their relationships by
the way this sounds very obstinate that
the way you are towards each other the
way the language that you used towards
the way you're addressing each other it
sounds like it's very you know it's not
like we're trying to win together it's
more like I want what I want and I want
what I want and that's that's not a good
sign for you guys so I would tell you
sit down and say okay we both have a
goal of owning a house someday I think
we can agree to that we both have a goal
of being on the same page in being an
agreement what is keeping us from doing
those two things
well he's uncomfortable with your stupid
use of the credit cards and you're
uncomfortable that he's moving towards a
house that you don't feel good like you
guys are ready for right now and so you
guys got to solve those things in order
to move forward because if you just
watch you're just gonna state each
other's throats all the time now we
would put you on a written budget that
both of you are combining your finances
and working together towards your goals
the goals we teach or baby step goals
the first one is a thousand dollars
saved the second one is your debt free
everything but your house and the third
one is to finish your emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses now if
you had no credit cards and you had a
budget that you were operating on and
you felt comfortable that everything was
okay with a debit card because you had
money because there's money in the
budget that you had to say so over the
two of you have combined your incomes
you've combined your goals you had ten
or fifteen thousand dollars sitting
there for an emergency fund and then you
saved up a down payment while buying a
home would be kind of a no-brainer at
that point and you'd be in a good shape
to do that the problem is you've got all
these tattered ends to this conversation
and as long as those tattered ends are
there none of this is gonna feel good
your your behavior with credit cards
isn't gonna feel good to him his wanting
to push you to buy a house you don't
feel ready for you don't feel heard you
don't feel like your vote counts in the
way that y'all are handling the
discussions and you're not gonna feel
comfortable with that and all of those
are valid concerns so you've got to
learn to work through those things and
get on the same page and work together
if you want to prosper hope that helps
you